hey guys hey everyone the little bit of
footage we saw looks really really
beautiful and I think a lot of us feel
like we know this world we know the
world of Peter Pan we've seen films
we've read the books so I really want to
hear how this specific immersive world
that you've created this this Neverland
is going to be different from from the
ones that we've seen in the past well
it's really sort of pizza pan for 2015
and it's a complete reframing of the of
the story as we know it and love it it's
it's a big world and it's beautiful and
bold and this is all our origin story of
how Peter became pan how fantastic um
tell me quickly guys what you thought of
Joe's vision for this world when he
first articulated it to you Levi why
don't we start with a beautiful script
and when he I met Joe and I spoke with
Joe with the rehearsal stage it was the
vision of his character who was
absolutely perfect idea and mm-hmm the
best one I couldn't have thought of it
so how about you Kurt when I first met
Joe he'd said you know I have a young
son that's been having nightmares and he
said I want to make this film as dark as
I possibly can to show every kid out
there that no matter how dark the fear
they can overcome you know the nightmare
and and and what they're afraid of and I
thought it was one of the most you know
beautiful things I've ever heard
yeah that's exquisite I can guarantee
you're gonna see Neverland like you have
never seen it before through Joe Rai
sighs the guy as you all know as a
visionary and one thing you may not know
by seeing it you probably presume it's
all green screen it was not Joe likes to
build a set so Neverland was a set it
was in a Hall I'm looking here this
famous Hall is probably three times the
size of this space Wow right was the
studio we shot it up in Cottington where
Nolan did all the Batman movies and
inception and it was incredible the
first day I got on set I was all dressed
up and I went out
to go and find Joe they said Joe wants
to have a look so we went out with the
ad or the second ad he couldn't find Joe
on the set it took about 15 minutes he
was lost under some mushroom somewhere
that kind of mushroom there's a lot of
music playing but anyway it was 4:00 in
the morning I don't know why but anyway
yeah he this guy's a visionary and it
was all our joy and pleasure I don't
know if we'll ever get to make movies
like that again so we want to take a new
trailer to show you guys so you're the
first let's have a look at this trailer
so you we talked a little bit more about
a little bit before this about this is
such a different vision for this world a
different vision for how all the factors
in Neverland come together and break
apart and it looks incredible I guess
also you mentioned that you built huge
practical sets and I wonder if that was
something that you decided to do early
on in the creative process or if once
you started to figure out how you were
going to shoot the film it made more
sense to go with practical sense versus
green screen and CGI which most people
would do free economy been less
expensive doing it in CGI and the big
the really big set was the forests and a
lot of action takes place there with the
village and everything and I just felt
that it would give us more of an
immersive experience making the movie it
would help Levi who's you know first
movie this is to understand where he is
and the world is in and also helped me
to understand where I was and I love
building physical things you know I love
I love building playgrounds for us all
to play in and and so that was the idea
of the set yeah was it did it feel like
a playground to you Levi it did yeah
first time I went there it was it was
like you've walked into another theme
park it was full of all these different
and cool things it was there's
mind-blowing Hugh and Garret you guys
both worked extensively with
green-screen I mean Tron I think you
just in a room probably just a green
room for three months
so how did this feel as actors to be
able to work in this practical world was
great it was I mean like he was even
saying every day was pretty magical you
know
Joe certainly has his way of keeping the
morale up within the crew and he'd be
playing music and we you know most days
we'd have a hundred and fifty two
hundred extras and you know every day
they're dancing and singing all the
crews dancing and singing it was it was
something that you know Joe and I both
kind of laughed at a lot of films sort
of before this we've done a lot of sort
of depressing or very dark kind of
stories and this was an opportunity sort
of it had as much fun as we could enjoy
the film and experience as much as we
could which we felt was sort of a rarity
and what we were sort of lacking so it
was it was definitely a playground it
was fantastic awesome something it's one
of the most fun movies I've ever made
Joe set the tone there's music playing
all the time
everyone had a great time and we were
shooting pan we're in Neverland that by
the way though pirate ships full scale
fully built there were four pirate ships
built weren't there we had four pirate
ships in a space about the size of this
hall it was incredible the costumes and
even down to rehearsals I mean a lot of
directors don't rehearse Joe had three
weeks of rehearsals we he had all the
pirates in a room there was a box with
clothes and he said okay guys go and
dress up makeup so for the next three
hours that's what we did we did improv
it was the whole thing was a complete
joy thing was though what was what was
in those boxes were only dresses yep
yeah we used to begin at the wrap party
was fantastic I think we have some
additional footage to take a look at
yeah we have some
exclusive new footage for you to look at
no one's seen this before I believe it
is the introduction of Blackbeard to the
film so it's his introduction and yeah
let's take a look to it there are
clearly no dentists in Neverland but
there is Han disinfectant he's pretty
crazy when I first met Joe he said you
know here's his an image I have in mind
for Blackbeard and he showed me a
picture which was my face superimposed
with the wig of Marie Antoinette and the
costume of louis xiv and i was like i
mean it's as crazy as Neverland should
be and every part of it I remember Joe
explaining to me that if you assume that
Neverland is a child's imagination that
adult should always be somehow
frightening and ridiculous at the same
time which is generally how kids see us
so which is right Levi we are
frightening and ridiculous right yes you
need to say no to that anyway but it was
all Jose Jose sort of world and his
vision from beginning to end
it's exciting also to see the fearsome
pirate being someone other than hook I
mean hook is really sympathetic you can
see at least in this beginning part of
it that he's a different guy so it'll be
interesting to fall in love with someone
who we've spent all this time hating in
this context he seems pretty sweet your
hook
give it time let's let's get an audience
question in here come on over
poison ivy yeah I'm Cheryl from New York
obviously when there's a lot of sources
of Peter Pan
I realize that you all wanted to create
your own identity but was there anything
that any of these sources that you went
to for inspiration in creating your
roles Thanks
thanks the way the main source material
for the movie was Berry's book Peter Pan
and for me the main inspiration from
that book was a sense of its strangeness
it's a very odd book it doesn't
underestimate the children's
intelligence and is quite dark but also
the characters there are no real goodies
or baddies even Peter is quite flawed he
is brave and bold and he also and a lot
of fun but he's also he steals other
people's ideas and he thinks he's above
reading and writing and in the end he
stabs hook in the back in a quite
dishonorable way so so I really loved
the kind of duplicity of all the
characters especially Peter but also her
kin and Tiger Lily and so on we are guys
this is also what we have to move on and
so I want you to give a huge round of
applause to the team
you